it's a summer of discontent amid
scorching temperatures record after
records set to be shattered in the
sweltering heat 85 million people are
under heat alerts it's really crazy you
can't even go outside really without
feeling like you're gonna pass out
and pair to the heat expectations of
more heavy rains after unprecedented
flooding in the northeast of the U.S a
direct consequence say experts of
climate change human caused climate
change also causes rainfall to be more
extreme a warmer atmosphere holds more
moisture so when a storm system comes
it's dumping out much larger amounts of
water California's death valley is
forecast to reach higher than 54 degrees
Celsius this weekend
in Texas officials are anxiously
monitoring the vulnerable power grid
demand for cooling power hitting a
record for the second day in a row and
the most vulnerable people are also
under threat in Las Vegas volunteers are
in homeless camps passing out much
needed supplies in the nation's capital
it's a balmy 86 degrees Fahrenheit
that's 30 degrees Celsius it's normal at
this time of the year but the White
House climate team is all too aware that
on a nationwide basis this is an anomaly
it's something that hits us every summer
but the intensity and the frequency of
these heat waves that we're seeing
scientists agree those are fueled by
climate change you know and this
president has called climate change a
crisis it's one of the top crises that
are affecting our nation
out of view under the ocean surface the
warming waters are bleaching coral on an
unprecedented basis the Florida Keys
literally would not exist if it were not
for the coral reef track that has
existed here over the Millennia
and away is an effort to change the
status quo Coral fragments being
cultivated in nurseries and then
replanted underwater a small but
significant reminder that climate change
can be counted although experts warn as
temperatures rise those efforts on
multiple fronts will become more urgent
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera Washington